so hello Priyanka hello tanzim thank you
for joining today's webinar we will be
starting in couple of minutes and
meanwhile we are waiting it would be
great if you guys could introduce
yourself in the chat box with your
educational background and research
interests
important
good evening ma'am
good evening
can you let me know of your educational
background and what are your research
interests
yes ma'am ma'am recently I'm pursuing I
am Tech biotechnology this is my uh last
semester and recently I have done two
projects in bioinformatics that were
basically uh on the r programming and my
interest basically is on the cancer
research
foreign
project again with our
uh sorry Mom your voice is breaking
sorry now hello am I audible now
hello
am I audible now
um I'm actually your voice is
continuously yes sugary uh actually
Priyanka uh you can try fixing your
network because sugar is yeah her
audible like her voice is really Audible
foreign
meanwhile I can type my
type in the chat and you can respond in
the chat
all right so I can see that couple more
of participants have joined so we are
waiting for a few more minutes to start
with today's webinar and meanwhile we
are waiting it would be great if the
participants could introduce yourself in
the chat box you can let us know about
your educational background and research
interests are you from a life science
background or are you from a computer
science background
foreign
I'm curious to know about your
educational background are you from a
microbiology or biotechnology we have
Priyanka with us she's from a
biotechnology background what are your
um
what is your background and you can also
let me know of your research interest as
well
uh so we have Shruti with us she is also
from an M Tech biotechnology background
from Amity University
what what are your research interest can
you let me know about that too
Priyanka is interested in cancer
research and she has a previous
experience working with our programming
and I'm curious to know about the rest
of you guys as well
all right so Priyanka says she is from
an M Tech biotechnology background and
she has done two projects in
bioinformatics that's pretty interesting
based on our programming and talking so
this is the interest in bioinformatic
increase and she is now interested in
doing cancer research and also using
some of the tools that are important in
mind map that's pretty interesting uh do
you have any specific
um area of oncology that you're
interested to work with
or have you uh previously checked out
any of our student projects that are
there on the portal we have numerous
students from MIT who has carried out
multiple uh oncology related projects
I can share them um during my
presentation as well so that everyone
can have a look into what are the
various ideas that students have already
worked on apart from oncology uh what
are rest of your research interests are
there anyone with machine learning
interest or infectious disease
also please feel free to unmute yourself
and answer as well if you find typing in
the chat is more complicated if so you
can unmute as well
and let me know
all right so Shruti has her research
interest in machine learning art
programming and want to learn Linux
and
um I'm also curious to know like how
would you rate your Proficiency in
bioinformatics ads is everyone a
beginner in mathematics or have you guys
uh I can say that few of the
participants have already worked with
bioinformatics project so we do have a
couple of intermediate and advanced
level participants
all our beginners in bioinformatics you
can let me know that as well in the chat
box
ma'am actually uh we have done some
projects so I think I can consider
myself as an intermediate but uh and I
now I will I'm also uh just want to
learn more Basics about the panformatics
and more tools as I say you before
so I I think that I'm under the uh
intermediate person
oh great thank you so much for sharing
Priyanka what about the rest of you guys
I'm curious to know about you guys as
well
I can only see the Shruti and Priyanka
are sharing their research interest and
background please feel free to
um share your interest as well
you would like to have it more
interactive you don't have to feel shy
or anything
all right uh also I can see that couple
of the participants have already joined
our program so
um can you let me know like who all has
joined the program
I guess Priyanka has joined
good evening
you have already joined right
yes ma'am
okay and uh what about the rest of you
guys have you already enrolled for the
program or are you guys waiting to
enroll
okay Shruti has also joined the program
okay Meda has also joined for the
program we do have couple of
participants who have joined uh what
about the rest of you guys have you guys
joined as well
[Music]
um you can also let me know like what is
your education background and what are
your research interests
truthy and Priyanka has shared it as
well
good evening mom
uh good evening
yeah Mom am I Audible yes you're Audible
yeah Mom so my name is
pursuing m-tech biotechnology from Amity
University I'm a final year student and
like I have interest in buying for since
past long time so I have worked on
projects which included drug discovery
and I have used some tools like Auto Doc
and swordinger and we have performed
many experiments like on finding out
drug targets and all but right now
through this program I'm Keen to learn
more about data science and machine
learning
oh all right so you have pretty similar
interests with Shruti she is also
interested in machine learning and she
also has done uh molecular talking
are you guys in the same patch as well
yes ma'am we are in the same class all
three
okay that's pretty interesting
uh do you have um any specific
research interests like uh using machine
learning which ads analysis would you
like to do
um are you interested in oncology or
infectious diseases
mama I have worked on infectious
diseases for like past two semesters so
I was thinking to go for something else
like
something in Neuroscience maybe because
I was not quite Keen about oncology
that's why I wanted to do something else
but I was confused during when I was
filling the forms so I just put my
interest in agriculture and biotech so
I'm not like pretty sure on what I can
work so I need a bit of guidance on what
new thing I can work now because from
past two semesters I have been working
with some infections and finding out
targets for viral diseases and also
that's why
okay all right we do have like a lot of
research fellows so I started from uh
zero and they have and they have been
able to even publish their research work
so along the presentation I can show you
like uh some of the student projects
that are there who have made use of
machine learning to study infectious
diseases oncology and so on
so
um meanwhile um let's start with today's
webinar and the participants can share
their education background and research
interests along the way so that we don't
have any delays so hello everyone a very
warm greeting to one and all my name is
Krishna Kumar and I would like to
welcome you all for today's webinar on
omixlogic bandsmetics and data science
research fellowship program so those of
you who are new to this webinar this
program has been designed to help young
researchers and students take advantage
of the bioinformatic resources for
analysis of complex High throughput Life
Science data and become well-versed in
bioinformatics and this program offers
you to participate in real and
cutting-edge renowned biometric research
and to be a part of the community and
the fellowship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mental guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a bioinformatics project
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based parents
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make balance marriage
more accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omics logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and visual coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omix data
analysis and students will also have
access to the omics logic resources but
how does it help Advance by informatics
teaching
omic's logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of science
Matrix it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is booming's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like RN Titan or even
beginning a data analysis project
and this also comes with an access to
the omen strategy courses which include
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-omics that includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and epigenomics data science that makes
use of R and python as well as chem
informatics
and example projects of different fields
that you could learn from and replicate
for your research work
and as a part of the program students
will also receive access to the T by
info platform wherein you will you will
be guided through the demo pipelines as
well as the data management and Analysis
Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinformatic pipelines and different
stages of analysis will be performed in
different sections on this multinomics
platform another important resource that
you get access to it is the omex logic
code playground which will help you
develop coding skills while learning
popular packages in R and python to
visualize annotate and analyze complex
patterns in biological data
and with so much data available on any
biological topic and question completing
a program seems like a great opportunity
but it can be challenging that is why we
also provide you with the opportunity to
seek mental guidance and learn alongside
an International Community of
bioinformatics and data science
enthusiasts
so now to view the various courses and
example projects we first need to sign
up on the omics logic learn portal
before that let me walk you through a
brief demo on what a completed profile
on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles and a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your education background and
research interests and the mentors can
view your programs under the activity
tab the courses you are currently
completing will appear under the courses
Tab and finally after the completion of
your coursework the certificates will
appear under the certificates tab so
that let us Begin by signing up on the
women's logic learn portal I'm sharing
the link for signing up on the portal in
the chat box
so that the participants can sign up on
the book as well all right shouldn't
have shared the link for signing up
so the participants
um and visit this link and I'll walk you
through the demo on how to sign up on
the portal so for those participants who
are new to the uh omixological and
portal you can simply click on the
create an account option that you see
here
and here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID and password you can
either login using any of these or you
also have the option to log in using any
of your social media handles for example
your Google account Facebook account
GitHub Apple account GitHub account or
even Twitter
and for those participants who already
have an account on the portal you can
simply click on login now and simply
click on sign in so with that I'll pause
for a couple of seconds for the
participants to sign upon the portal and
once you have signed up please put a yes
in the chat box so that I can take you
along and show you the various courses
and projects that students have
completed
I'm monitoring the chat box for your
response
and the participants who have already
signed up you can put a done in the chat
box so I know that you already have an
account on the portal
so I'm expecting uh responses from the
10 plus participants that we have
um you can put a yes in the chat box
once you have signed up and if you
already have an account on the portal
you can simply
um put done in the chat box so that I
know that you already have a
pre-existing account on the portal
all right so sulagna says done so she
already has an account on the portal
Priyanka says she has also uh signed up
Neda also says sign up
I'm waiting for few more responses in
the chat box and I'll proceed along and
show you the various uh
courses and example projects that will
be useful to you during your project
dissertation
and if you have any queries you can
leave that in the chat as well and I'll
be happy to guide you if you are facing
any technical issues
all right so along the way you can leave
your responses in the chat I'm going to
proceed along and show you the various
courses that are there
so once you sign up on the portal you
will be able to see the various courses
that are there courses and example
projects that are there on the portal so
let's say you have a specific let's say
you are a complete beginner to the field
of bioinformatics and you want to get
started in this field so if so you you
have courses on introductory band
Fanatics that you can take a look at
that is course one introduction to
bankmatics and bytes and molecules and
since a lot of the participants already
have a prior experience working in
bioinformatics and they already have a
predefined research interest
um I'll walk you through the various
courses that makes use of the concept so
we have couple of participants who are
interested in machine learning so you
can simply enter the keyword that you're
interested to work with in the search
bar that asks you for a specific course
and that will show you the various
courses and example projects that are
making use of the machine learning
Concepts and I can also see that a
couple of participants are interested in
oncology
so you can simply enter oncology that
will show you the various
um example projects that are there
ranging from breast cancer to liver
cancer and so on so you can have a take
a look at this at your own pace
but for now coming to the part where I
was talking about updating your account
you can simply click on the welcome back
tab that says with your email ID
and here you will see an uh icon that's
his profile so once you click on this
you will be able to edit all the
features that I was talking about in my
presentation that is your profile image
your bio that will consist of your
educational background and research
entrance your name has to be in full
proper capitalization as well and you
can also link your social media hand
such as LinkedIn and Orchid ID as I have
um linked here and now as I mentioned
this is the activity tab wherein the
mentor of your program and the community
manager will be tracking your learning
progress and once you start taking up
any of the courses and example projects
that will show up under the core system
and once you complete your dissertation
project and publish it on our portal you
will be able to view it under the
projects Tab and you also have the
programs tab there and you'll be able to
see the research fellowship program that
you have imported and finally after the
completion of the quizzes and Associated
assignment you will receive the
certificates under the certificates
so um this is
um how to navigate the portal and
another interesting part that I want to
show you is how to check out other
student projects that are there on the
portal I'm sharing the link in the chat
box
foreign
s have published a wide variety of
projects on topics ranging from
astrobiology infectious diseases
oncology Precision medicine machine
learning and so on you can have it take
a look at it you can simply enter uh the
keywords that you're interested in
similar to how you were looking for your
coursework and example projects so if
say you're interested in Neuroscience
you can simply enter the keyword
neuroscience and that will show you a
lot of the research topics that is
transcriptomic profiling machine
learning for neuroscience and genomics
for neuroscience and so on so you can
take a look at this and let me know if
you have any queries you can let me know
in the chat as well so now to more to
the next part of today's webinar I would
like to invite Dr Mohit malzindar who is
also going to be one of the mentors of
the research fellowship program to give
you a brief introduction Dr Mohit
mazumdar has over 12 years of research
and Industry experience he has completed
a masters in bioinformatics from Jamia
islamia and has a PHD in computational
biology and chemistry from jawaharlal
University he is an expert in machine
learning and application to biomedical
and chemical data and with that brief
introduction the stage is all yours
thank you srikari
and hello everyone
pleasure to meet you all
and welcome to the session I'm really
glad to meet with you all today and very
excited to talk about one of the best
research experience or program which we
have developed as a company while
working as a startup in a very Niche
domain which is bioinformatics and
biomedical data science
so I know that many of you have already
been part to the first session that we
did yesterday I think some of you were
there and uh those who are joining for
the first time
um
um
my name is Mohit mazumdar and to tell
you briefly I'm working at the
intersection of Academy and Industry
with the aim to develop a large capacity
to for the Healthcare System especially
in India and elsewhere as as well
so since 2019 we have launched the omics
logic in India with an initial
collaboration with several universities
where we piloted our training and worked
with faculty to develop programs and
training and research that addresses the
major Gap in bioinformatics education so
since then we have been working with
students from partner universities going
through training and project work and
faculties who are interested to utilize
the collaborative research platform to
incorporate project-based bioinformatics
and data science research to their
analysis
uh so uh it's it's it has been a very
thrilling Journey for us and this
experience has enabled us to work on a
variety of challenges that comes with
the training and translational research
and that's why we are saying that we
will be able to work on infectious
diseases cancer Neuroscience space omics
and you have an option to choose from an
array of research that you want to do
and we will be able to support that and
the reason is that because uh we come
with this agenda like our company has
this agenda to bring awareness about
data driven Healthcare research and we
are that's why we are reaching out to
all of you to make bioinformatics and
high quality data-driven research
accessible to everyone so in a way we
want to be the disruptors in the field
of biological data science research and
that is how by providing these industry
grade cutting-edge training and support
at a lowest possible cost compared to
what is available in the industry
and this engagement so far has helped us
to collect data and tremendously improve
our learning models so after many
programs we have coordinated and as you
know that we are a data science driven
company so we do data science for
everything for data collection for uh
you know uh for calculation of different
types of models uh which is also
business models not just
um Computing not just just research
models so after many programs
coordinated with the universities we
have over a thousand students from India
and then we saw that there's a major Gap
in skills and then we we're thinking
that the best way is to integrate this
as a research experience like a research
project where you know or learn about to
how do you think critically about data
and apply appropriate analysis methods
to the right data so that is very
challenging otherwise
uh about the program yes uh in uh last
year 2021 I think 2021 is now two years
ago uh we uh we we signed an mou and uh
one of the reasons that this program is
available with the lowest cost to The
Amity student is because of this mou
because in here Amity University and we
signed for a long-term collaboration and
in on top of that double by informatics
Research Center was also involved so the
um the scholarships that we provide are
also supported by the top Research
Institute making it the lowest cost
research fellowship program in uh in all
around the world so uh
so we as as I said the theme includes
people from fine biotech U.S Prime
biotech India and in Israel uh topper by
informatics Research Center is uh Israel
and we have a group of scientists who
supports this program so you get you are
in really really great hands and along
with that the faculty from the uh from
Amity University your University are
really uh collaborating and helping and
we are working together so that uh we
can do several other things along with
the research and along with like big
term projects and translational research
industry related research
commercialization of some products and
henceforth
ah similarly we are working with some of
the Prime institutes as you saw that uh
for industry as well as Academia we are
working with Pharma industry and we are
developing uh content and training and
uh placements for people who are
interested in such disciplines so these
sort of training programs are also
available which are like an intermediate
level training programs and we are also
connected with the AI and uh drug
Discovery companies and we are building
resources we are using also doctors and
Healthcare data and hospitals and all of
that so that we not only learn about
genetic data and we we can con actually
complete the picture of system biology
and also like information from a patient
level data information about these
different different parameters that also
play very very important roles so
integrating all of this you get a really
clear picture of how the health care or
health informatics or this the entire
Healthcare System could be challenged
and could be improved by incorporating
these things which are not usually done
in India so that's our purpose to be
able to do it in India and effectively
and also worldwide where there is a gap
there is a There's an opportunity
similarly for NGS industry the price of
Next Generation sequencing is getting
less and less but there is still a
problem with data analysis so the data
analysis is still something that India
is not realizing to be a thing right now
because the data generation is not so
high but yeah I mean various companies
like 150 companies have mushroomed in
last two years because they realize that
this is like going to change another
reason is that after covet pandemic you
know that the data uh at least genomic
data is now talked about a lot and the
government is kind of uh supporting that
and they are seeing the results from
this carti experiments and all where
like Gene editing to all those
technologies that we use to address very
challenging diseases such as cancers
which were non-curable at at every point
of time during this entire history but
right now there is a possibility to get
the people well you know keyword but all
of this is very very expensive to be
able to do even in the US like in India
obviously and there are two hospitals
who have started it and in India you
know that we specialized in low cost so
we are trying to build that kind of uh
technology research and those are some
of the opportunities that the
users or like the students will should
be aware of because in the future it
will all be you know in that context
now uh for the winters like every
semester we will have like a bunch of
programs that we do you'll find us like
posting a lot on social media and
sharing a lot of emails because we have
a collaboration with around uh 30
universities across the globe so some
many of them are in the U.S so in the US
there are four semesters uh um which are
trimesters so in the winter trimester we
will be conducting these programs so
these are also available online for
anyone to join which is Introduction to
multiomics biomedical data science and
art biomedical data Sciences in Python
chem informatics for biomedical drug
Discovery this will start on 27th
January a Miss logic transcriptomics is
an in-depth transcriptomics analysis and
Healthcare Health learning for machine
learning for healthcare informatics so
these are the winter semester programs
that we are going to do where where
students from us Africa and other
countries and even in India we will join
um now about the research fellowship
program that many you of you have joined
and also many of you are thinking to
join is is is kind of a combination of
all of this because research fellowship
program is a research training and it's
more driven for research projects that
could that you could do during this ntcc
time so if you are thinking if you have
four to five P month of time with you
what is the best uh that you can do with
that so if you are thinking that you
want a career in life sciences you want
a career in biotechnology or Healthcare
I think then you should consider this
program because this is a kind of
becoming Quant essential for the future
in next four three four years things are
going to be in place in utilization from
doctors to recommendation systems to
tests all the Diagnostics to prognostics
everywhere machine learning and AI are
going to be used and what they are going
to be using they are using they're going
going to use the healthcare data so and
that's what we are trying to teach you
and that's what we are trying to do
research on and that's where the
discoveries are happening that's where
the companies are forming in research
that's where there is revenue and that's
where that is job opportunities
so um and to be able to provide this as
I said we keep on meeting and improving
and thinking and discussing that what
are the ways to improve uh help students
and develop such research projects which
requires a lot of brainstorming so we do
it on campus we visit quite often and uh
and then we collaborate to work together
on some of these things that developing
learning models and implementing
learning models for students who come
from a very basic background that people
who have not exposed to this these
fields they want a fresh perspective and
it's always good to start from the
beginning because you develop the basic
understanding and there are different
levels but all of this is very easy to
do first of all and very interesting to
do as well because if it is boring you
know if it is lengthy I think many
students will lose interest that is a
normal thing to have that could happen
so that's why way you see that in our
last program also like 40 students
completed their projects all those do
join except I think one or two who never
like uh who are never there we tried our
best even with them but like even like
98 of the students were able to do a
good project even after providing giving
very less time some of them uh how do
how how is that possible and how is that
uh made into this uh that is what is
made into this into International
educational system that we have
developed so in this
um like for example many of you said
that you are interested in neuroscience
and you're interested in infectious
disease or whatever research area you're
interested in that research area will
use some data that research area will
use some technology so when you start
your basic training you know that
research area if you know that is fine
if you don't know we have the basic
coursework that that introduces you to
those different research areas so you
can easily develop like okay covered or
Ebola or you know breast cancer or lung
cancer or
Alzheimer's or multiple sclerosis so
even like we see people suffering we
sometimes like think that if if I can
work on this some non some disease which
is like uh related to
different types of problems that you see
around so that's the point like finding
the disease is easy but then finding
data is important the right kind of data
that will give you like maybe a poster
or like some some good outcome that you
can Showcase in your CV which will be
very important in the after the end of
this so that that is the part where
mentors are needed where our team is
there to help you out so basic training
to these intermediate Advanced Training
then specialization you we have project
data sets so you start working on data
sets so uh like even for the coursework
like many people are like why do I need
to do coursework again it's not like
coursework coursework it's like
tutorials because you need to use the
platforms you need to learn how to do
the data analysis so there are obviously
for any software you have to learn you
have to go to the tutorials and see how
things are done so that's how the
coursework is built it's all practical
so it's not boring because it's all
practical and again like there are
Concepts that you need to learn that
will definitely going to help you there
are keywords that you need to learn that
that is what you're going to tell in the
interviews that is what you're going to
like write in the letters and also like
for higher education for Masters for PhD
so all of this will be useful
so these are some of the things the
outcomes from this so after you do the
data sets you and you start working on
the project so these are different steps
but this is very easy to do in that
context of and why we have made it like
in such an easy way to do it there's a
reason the reason is that like we know
that you are not scientist and some of
this research is done at a very
scientific level like big labs are
working doing people are doing this
research at a PhD level but what if you
start now so you if you start now you
you by the time you maybe reach Masters
level or PhD level you have four five
six years of experience and that is the
experience you need to you know get on
you need you need to have to land a good
job I mean you will see that any job
that are posted they will ask for two to
three years of experience but as a
beginner at any level you started even
after Masters or PhD you're a beginner
so why not start this at this time
whenever you are like and develop that
experience so that your more you know
you are more and more eligible for all
the opportunities that are out there
so as I was telling you this is
automated and uh this is uh not only
automated but there is a code no code
way so you can use the automated way you
can also use the coding way so if you
are interested in quoting
you can go for coding but if you're not
if if you think that you are more
interested in finding a solution or
finding the right answer or doing
something important then you can use the
platform and do the research and then go
do further Downstream research or
analysis which requires some coding
experience so that what kind of coding
experience it requires well R and python
are used are are one of the most common
data science related coding languages
but in biology what we do is not we are
not writing codes from the very basic we
are using already some of the libraries
and the reason being is that these
libraries are like they have algorithms
they have uh the visualization
application so you will when you start
coding you'll learn about these
different libraries that we call to do a
task because if you start writing
everything from the basic you will end
up have you will end up with a million
lines of code which is not possible
obviously so in coding also all these
automations work you need to know how to
call the library and write a command so
those those are the things that you need
to learn that how to apply R and python
for uh bioinformatics for data analysis
for any type of data analysis not just
like biological data you can then do it
for any kind of data and integrate so
those are the things that you need to
consider when you're when you are
working as a biologist and not go into
deep puff you know things which are not
relevant for for you
and now uh learning platforms these are
commercial platforms industry great
platforms because we are using these
platforms for industry research so we
have a team uh we have the entire topper
bioinformatics Research Center who is
working with bigger cancer research
institutes bigger companies and they're
using the same platform for industry
great bioinformatics or industry grade
data driven research now these are like
ucss Stanford all bigger universities as
well so you are also getting access to
the same platform to learn about it and
this has made written in a way and put
it together in a graphical way so that
anyone can learn and apply and use this
for their own research now we have
different types of research which is
also ongoing which is very interesting
it's like you you see that obesity is a
problem or you see that obesity has a
huge market like people are buying so
many products related to you know uh to
become Slimmer or liquid good so all of
that work can be done through
bioinformatics research and nowadays
because of the microbiome because of you
know all this tests that are available
and all those different types of
opportunities it has so just this is
just not you know traditional
bioinformatics this is like modern and
Advanced bioinformatics Data science and
biomedical data science so this is the
opportunity that we are trying trying to
bring which I think is a very uh niche
in its uh in its way but also very
important and going to be very important
so we what we do is that we have
Workshop more we will be doing workshops
and we will be also doing regular
sessions during this entire training
process and we will be giving you this
sort of coursework where you will learn
about how to design a bioinformatics
research project so once you are once
you know how genomics is applied how
transcriptomics or metagenomics is
applied to data or how can you apply a
clinical uh data to research then you
start thinking about the project and
that there are different steps in the
project so research topic finding a good
topic
data set finding the good data set and
then summarizing your data set that what
kind of information and actually what
kind of analysis you can do on data set
and then because these are high
dimensional so one of the reason we are
using the tower platform when we are not
using like any web server or you know
our own own computers is because this is
high dimensional data which is very big
in size like it's in gigabyte it
sometimes sits in terabytes and I mean
we are doing alignment of these bigger
genomes together so just imagine the
computational power it requires so that
power is provided by the tower by
informatics Research Center and that's
why also this is a commercial platform
because it's not possible to give it
like it's just not possible to give it
for free for anyone no one is giving it
for free because it is very
computationally expensive so that's kind
of the capability that you get to start
your exploratory analysis where you run
your PCA you see that what kind of
patterns you can find from the unknown
data and then you start your analysis
from there and find patterns and find
those in clues that will help you find
the kind of right Gene find the right
target or something which is new and
unique and that's the beauty of all of
this because what we are doing each with
each of the project is that finding
something new and unique not repeating
something that is also an option but
from there you have to grow more like
what people have done but what more I
can do what more I can find and that's
what we have been able to do in a very
short period of time which is why this
research Fellowship is one of the best
programs that we offer it's like a mini
PhD and that even undergraduate and even
high school students have been able to
do so there are different stages and
steps as I was telling you
and then for every step we have also
like this weekly progress report which
srigara SRI gauri uh reaches out to the
participants and we have our team who
help you out with all of these steps how
to do it like what to write and what
kind of analysis we connect we are
connected through Skype and we are
connected through different types of uh
other uh like WhatsApp and all so we are
always there to help students when they
were in need and when they are facing
challenges and all of this ended ends in
recognition and it will be beneficial
for you in every step of your career and
that is very much guaranteed because
that's how the pattern has been and uh
many of us has gone through the same
steps so
uh so that analysis so as I was telling
you about different steps analysis and
then writing so these are different
steps that we have uh uh like put
together for you to understand how to
work on a project identifying a topic
like in every step you will find mentors
to help you out so this is Mentor guided
training plus it is also like with a lot
of other resources so if you can you can
also do it on your own like all of this
because everything is there like but
also uh if you can't we are always there
to help you and we have this sessions
all of that to be able to help you but
all of these options are there for you
to learn and also like one of the
biggest advantages is to online
infrastructure and because of this you
can work at your own convenient time at
your own convenient place uh at the same
time if you work uh in in the university
in the lab that would be also so great
because in that you will be able to do
it in a shorter period of time short
period of time in a strict number of
hours
so a lot of outcomes we have
Publications we have posters with
universities with research institutes
people have got uh PhD full-time
fully funded phds in a institutes which
are of very high repute
and also been have got like awards at
different uh important and like good
conferences and I watched given by
companies and all
so some of the outcomes that are for
sure which are there is that to
understand the challenges you will know
that what is going on in this industry
what is going on and what uh what are
the different types of uh research and
projects that are there uh and you will
get trained and trained and get skills
for sure because you will be able to
unders you will be able to uh
just a second yeah you will be able to
work and develop the skill sets and then
you will be able to work on your
independent research project and publish
and work on the publication as well so
here are some of the Publications and
all we have over uh eight to ten
Publications that came from last year's
research and then I wanted to show you
some of those people who have finished
last time from undergraduate like BSC
zoology uh
Gotham was able to work in a very short
period of time collect a lot of Point
certificates and work on his very
specialized research area of complete
his project record his project and uh
contribute uh which is with this
published project similarly like there
was there were a lot of students who did
really well like all of them I think did
really well and uh also get a good cgpa
and sgpa through the project and that
has really helped them to get a really a
good outcome from their degree also
because of the points and all and then
we have students who were able to work
on either infectious diseases like SARS
scope to Wastewater sample so this is
what China is doing right now the
surveillance from the Wastewater samples
many places in India is going to
complement that as well
so these are some Cutting Edge stuff
that students have been able to work on
and uh they were able to complete these
projects publish these projects and get
like really a lot of recognition in
Amity also while doing their
presentation of the finished projects
because they did thorough work and did a
lot of other activity also that helped
them got got in got placed in good
companies as well as go for higher
education and reputed
universities and organizations so that's
uh that's what people have been able to
do and along with that people there is
also an entrepreneurship path so you can
use this project to develop
to develop like a minimum viable product
so some some of the group members did
that in the recent hackathon which
includes microbiome in health and
wellness where the team developed a
micro preg predictor that is an
all-in-one Wellness solution for
understanding and predicting the
likeliness of infections in vaginal
infections STIs and other complications
so it's a predictive tool that they have
built and they would want to
commercialize it and make it a product
and become come out as a startup so this
entire startup process and
Entrepreneurship is also supported by
the same kind of training and to be able
to do this we have industrial Partners
from around the globe uh some of them
are at the one of the top organizations
in technology or research or sciences
and also academic Partners from the
greatly reputed universities in India we
also have and including your University
so
um that's about my a part of the
presentation I think maybe I'll
I'll invite again Shri gauri to see if
there are any questions and if we can
maybe discuss anything else
thank you so much sir so we'll pause for
a couple of seconds if the participants
have any queries please feel free to
either share it in the chat or you can
also unmute yourself
and they'll be happy to answer
[Music]
[Music]
uh in the chat box I've also shared a
couple of links to the student projects
as well as the team by info platform
that you you will be making use of along
your program duration and also have
shared a link to the research
Publications that students have been
able to do after the completion of their
projects you can have a take a look at
them as well they have been published in
reading journals and some are also in
the pre-planform who have plans to
publish their work in Reading terms and
uh you can also
um get to know more about these we'll
we'll be emailing out to you a brochure
so that you can get all of these details
in one place so for that um the
participants uh can share their email
IDs those who wish to get uh the
brochure in their emails so that we can
email it out
and we can also share the scholarship
um related queries as well
is asking how to enroll in the research
fellowship and how to proceed from there
yeah so sulagna I think
um shubham here is here he will be able
to connect with you uh maybe give you a
call and tell you about different
options so research Fellowship in the
brochure we have and also in the website
there is a
um there is a link to submit the fee but
uh I think for Amity students we have
the scholarship the most scholarship the
lowest price Model available so that I
think shubham will be able to help you
out with so you will connect shubham
will email you and also like connect
with you if you have your phone number
you can share that as well and he'll
give you a call and tell you about the
details
foreign
we are waiting for any more queries that
the participants are having
for those who are sharing their emails
we can um email out the brochure and the
scholarship uh related details as well
[Music]
I'm also sharing the link to the email
ID of our marketing manager so that you
can also get connected with her as well
if you have any queries
so this is the email ID
um of the marketing manager you can
reach out to her at marketing
omicslogic.com and I've also shared her
contact number which is also active on
WhatsApp so that students can reach out
to her at any point of time if they're
having any queries
uh Priyanka is asking um I'm trying to
update profile but when I'm trying to
add my LinkedIn profile the update
option becomes disabled okay uh we'll
look we look into that can you share
your email ID Priyanka
in the chat box
so that we can share your query with the
technical team and they will be looking
into it
thank you so much Priyanka
all right then if the participants have
no further queries
um we'll be ending today's meeting
and if everyone has shared their email
IDs
we can email out the workshop and the
scholarship details as well
all right then thank you so much
everyone for joining today's webinar and
we look forward to seeing you at the
research fellowship program thank you so
much
thank you thank you everyone
[Music]